vous allez en projet d'acheter un
smartphone reconditionnés vous avez
raison parce que c'est bien pour votre
portefeuille et c'est aussi bien pour la
planète sauf que et vous le savez
peut-être pas ya pas mal de pièges pas
malde embuscade dans lesquelles vous
risquez de tomber et au final est
déchanter avoir des déconvenues une pas
être content de ce qui se passe derrière
il ya plein de choses à venir regarder
lorsqu'on va acheter reconditionnés mais
on ne le sait pas alors vous avez de la
chance je suis là pour nous aider c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui réalisé en
partenariat avec smart smart key un
reconditionnement français mais s'empale
un peu plus loin dans la vidéo et je
vous dirai justement pourquoi aller
acheter chez smart et vous allez voir
que tous ces différents points et bien
on les a regardés on en a discuté avec
smart et ils n'ont pointé du doigt tous
les pièges à éviter donc merci à smart
et puis on reparlera justement de smart
et de tous les avantages de venir et htc
smart mais à la fin de la vidéo mais en
toute chose on va commencer tout de
suite dans le premier piège et on y va
maintenant
[Musique]
la première chose avoir en tête c'est
que le prix ne fait pas tout souvent
quand on va acheter reconditionnés que
c'est soit par envie parce qu'on ne veut
pas acheter neuf ou bien souvent c'est
parce que on n'a pas les moyens
d'acheter un flagship donc on va venir
acheter un produit qui a une génération
d'avant voire deux générations d'avant
et on va toucher beaucoup moins cher et
ça c'est cool sauf que le prix ne fait
pas tout et c'est le premier piège
attention aux prix le prix une fois de
plus je le dis je le redis ne fait pas
tout parce que le prix doit inclure
beaucoup de choses le prix n'inclut pas
juste le prix du produit lorsque trop
facile trop beau le prix la livraison
c'est pas tout d'ailleurs il doit y
avoir un reconditionnement de qualité il
ya des employés qualifiés à payer il ya
un ace à lever ya tout qui se paye
d'ailleurs donc si on veut juste choisir
le meilleur prix et si on va sur
n'importe quel reconditionneurs et bien
il se peut qu'à un moment ou un autre on
déchante et ça c'est important il faut
le savoir le deuxième point c'est
l'origine du produit attention beaucoup
de produits reconditionnés qui circulent
en france ou ailleurs viennent du monde
entier des états unis de la chine de
n'importe où où on a souvent peur ou pas
traçabilité et chatin smartphones ne
sont pas conformes aux spécificités
techniques européennes et pourrait donc
il une partie des fonctionnalités qui ne
fonctionne pas en france et ça pourrait
être un peu ballot l'astuce que je vous
donne ici c'est toujours regarder la
provenance du produit et s'il
reconditionneurs ne marque pas
demandez-lui d'où vient le produit que
je vais acheter quelle est son origine
de quel pays est-ce qu'on a peu
traçabilité derrière c'est aussi un
élément extrêmement important que doit
venir guider votre choix le troisième
point sait où et comment ils les
reconditionner ne pas acheter n'importe
quel smartphone c'est extrêmement
important il faut savoir qu'il ya 100
millions de smartphones qui dorment dans
les tiroirs des français dans les
tiroirs dans les plats cadre les
commodes ou vous voulez mais ils dorment
ça veut dire que potentiellement vous
avez 100 millions de smartphones alors
attention il peut y avoir des
smartphones de très anciennes
générations peut-être même des
téléphones mais ces produits pensés 100
millions de nap probablement qu'on
pourrait remettre sur le marché et qui
pour avoir une seconde 3e 4e vie si on
les remet sur le marché sur leur donne
une seconde chance il ya plusieurs
avantages le premier ses mots pour le
vendeur si vous en avez un qui dorment
vous le mettez en montrer retirer
quelque chose d'avoir un peu d'argent
plutôt qu'avoir un truc qui donne dans
votre placard et qui ne sert strictement
à rien et deuxième point est plus
important je pense c'est un circuit
court mieux vaut avoir un produit qui a
été donnée par un français et qui
ensuite être reconditionnés en france
est rachetée en france non pas pour
faire du franco-français mais juste
parce que les circuits courts sont bien
meilleures pour l'environnement et ça
évite de faire venir un smartphone qui a
fait quatre facteurs la planète avant
d'arriver chez vous d'autant plus que si
vous achetez un smartphone qui a été
vendu en france et reconditionnés
potentiellement en france eh bien il
aura les normes cee et ça c'est bien et
c'est là où il faut faire attention
aussi c'est pas suffisant de venir
acheter sur un site qui vend en france
où kapinos sur rue en france mais il
faut être saurez pas plus que les
produits viennent de france ou à défaut
d'europe et bah oui il ya des normes
européennes sa garantie déjà un peu pas
mal de choses tout en sachant que si
vous achetez saison reconditionneurs
français laborde davantage de garanties
sur les process les pièces la sécurité
des produits et en plus de ça en france
vous avez une certification qui est
quand même gage de garantie et ça en or
pâle un peu plus tard en tout cas un peu
plus loin dans la vidéo quatrième point
et c'est probablement l'un des plus
importants ne pas se tromper sur le
vendeur le vendeur ou le distributeur
est super important parce que vous allez
avoir des sites qui reconditionne eux
mêmes les smartphones il voulait
revendre et vous allez également avoir
des marketplace des places de marché où
vous allez venir acheter un produit qui
était reconditionnée par d'autres
achetés en france permet d'être sûr
qu'on va acheter saison reconditionneurs
français qui dépend du code du commerce
français donc en cas de litige il n'y a
pas d'embrouillé sinon il ya les
tribunaux ça c'est pas mal aussi mon
astuce ici c'est vraiment de venir vous
renseigner sur la nationalité du vendeur
si vous êtes sur un site propriétaire le
site du vendeur le site du
reconditionneurs et que c'est lui qui
redit sa dette écrit noir sur blanc vous
recherchez vous voyez où est ce qu'ils
les poutres ombres et les infos si vous
êtes sur une marketplace regardait le
nom du reconditionneurs et n'hésitez pas
à venir le googleliser pour voir où est
ce qu'ils sont et où est ce qu'il veut
nous reconditionnés vous pourrez
normalement trouver quand même pas mal
d'informations sur google normalement en
théorie et si vous n'en trouvez pas
passer votre chemin sait-on jamais le 5
1 points qui est également extrêmement
important et qui découlent de tout ça
c'est le sav attention au service après
vente en cas de problème il faut pouvoir
avoir un interlocuteur si votre produit
est défectueux c'est une fonctionnalité
qui ne marche pas ou s'ils arrivent en
mauvais état qui est ce que vous allez
venir contacter comment est ce que vous
allez faire valoir votre droit il faut
pouvoir avoir un contact un téléphone
c'est mieux qu'un email c'est mieux
qu'un chat qui vous allez pouvoir
contacter et qu'est ce qu'on va vous
dire il faut que vous ayez
interlocuteurs qu'ils soient formés
réactif et capable de vous répondre
assez rapidement parce que souvent quand
on achète un téléphone ce qu'on en a
besoin et ben oui citron t'achèterai pas
d'autant plus que si vous achetez à
l'étranger je ne sais où si vous avez un
problème vous allez devoir vous renvoyer
le produit à vos frais peut-être à des
milliers de kilomètres ça pour aussi
vous coûte relativement cher rentrée
d'expédition en plus de cent vient
rajouter le temps du transit le temps
qui soit réceptionnée ouvert traité et
qu'il revienne à bout autant dire que
c'est rapidement la galère et que c'est
extrêmement mauvais pour l'environnement
tandis que si vous achetez chez un
reconditionneurs français qui a le sav
qui est pas trop loin du service
réparation et bien vous êtes sûr que ça
va aller beaucoup plus vite ce sera plus
réactif c'est coûtera moins cher c'est
pas rare moins de temps et ça sera bien
meilleur pour la planète de ça dépend la
question bien évidemment de la gare
entier c'est le sixième point quelles
sont les garanties prises en charge par
votre conditionneurs attention les
règles sont pas les mêmes partout si
vous achetez c'est en reconditionneurs
aux ruelles pas les mêmes garanties
qu'un reconditionneurs en europe et qui
en reconnaissant d'air en france ça il
faut le savoir regardez bien sûr le site
lorsque vous allez acheter qu'est-ce
qu'il vous garantissent qu'est ce qui
est pris en charge dans les garanties et
quels sont les délais aussi important
une fois de plus et puis je dirais que
le septième choix peut-être le plus
important c'est fait le choix d'un bon
reconditionneurs vous prenez tous ces
éléments le produit la provenance la
garantie le côté éco responsable le
service après vente et vous allez avoir
un espèce de portrait robot du
reconditionnement dans lequel il faut
aller est ce qui nous renvoie au tout
premier point la question du prix mieux
vaut payer un peu plus cher mais avoir
du service parce que le jour où vous
aurez un problème vous serez très
heureux de vient trouver le service
derrière tout ça ça nous rende ou et
bien ça nous renvoie chez smart alors
smart c'est une boîte que j'ai visité il
ya quelques mois il ya quelques mois
smart m'a dit yamoussoukro voudrait bien
beau sac toit via chez nous vient voir
on tour les portes de l'usiné et tu
verras par toi même et j'ai vu par moi
même j'en ai fait une vidéo d'ailleurs
allé la voir je mets le lien en bas dans
la description smart sans
reconditionneurs qui est juste au pied
du pic saint loup qui réceptionne les
produits qu'il était ce qui leur met une
note en entrée puis s'il ya besoin va
venir réparer tout ce qu'il faut
directement ils ont tous les composants
il vient de les réparer ils vont même
jusqu'à de la micro sous diouf sont des
gens formés en interne pour faire de la
micro soudure si besoin le produit
ensuite et retester réévalué et les
notes finales c'est la note sur laquelle
vous allez l'acheter vous directement
sur le site de smart et si vous avez un
problème vous avez lu sav qui est juste
à côté ils vont me dire vous répondre
directement au téléphone répondre à vos
questions et l'atelier de réparation
dans une autre pièce juste à côté donc
vous avez tout le côté reconditionnement
tout le côté elle savait tous côtés
réparation à côté et en plus de ça ils
ont un truc qui est vachement bien c'est
qu'ils viennent former des gens aux
métiers du reconditionnement qui
deviennent embauchés après ou pas est
une vraie implication dans le tissu
local en achetant chez smart vous avez
toutes les garanties le sav à côté tout
est en français en plus de ça ils ont
des certifications la certification
services france garantie qui garantit
que tous autre conditionnement et le sav
sont situés en france je voulais dit au
pied du pic saint-loup servi par mes
propres yeux et ils sont certifiés sgs
qualicert reconditionnés qui garantit le
process industriel indispensable un
reconditionnement de qualité toute la
chaîne du reconditionnement et sur place
maîtrisez vous êtes tranquille et on a
une traçabilité des produits de la
réception jusqu'au recyclage il ya
certains produits qui partiront au
recyclage et il travaille avec des
produits recycleur français spécialisé
vous avez 24 mois de garantie plutôt
bien et vous propose de garanties
équivalentes aux 9 et en cas de problème
ils s'engagent à vous trouver une
solution sous 5 jours ateliers autant
vous dire qu'ici smartgauge toutes les
cases tous les pièges qu'on souhaite
éviter et bien smart vous les évite donc
je vous invite à venir faire une seule
chose qui vous voulez acheter un
smartphone reconditionnés vous cliquez
sur le lien en bas d'un description vous
allez jeter un coup d'oeil chez smart et
vous verrez que c'est une entreprise
sérieuse qui propose des produits super
intéressant à différents tarifs merci à
vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
d'ailleurs dit moi vous si vous avez
relevé d'autres points qui pourrait être
un petit peu touchy ou en retour
d'expérience un peu négatif relâche à
reconditionner marque elle et moi juste
en bas en commentaire d'ici là prenez
soin de vous embrasser puis à très
bientôt pour continuer à bien évidemment
à parler de teck de tous les côtés et ça
c'est chouette nous on va visiter
[Musique]